fillon il est en face de moi que des
histoires et plus aux fouilles plus plus
on sent la corruption plus on sent la
triche cette année pas de débat entre
tous les candidats à la présidentielle
avant le premier tour et pourtant en
2017 ce débat a eu lieu et ça fait des
étincelles tout ça ça illustre ce coup
là c'est pour la police ça ça illustre
ouais quand nous les convoqués par la
police nous vous voyez par exemple on a
pas d'immunité ouvrière désolé haut
niveau
en 2017 les onze candidats à la
présidentielle débattent sur un même
plateau de télévision avant le premier
tour un débat inédit dans l'histoire de
la vème république et les règles sont
strictes positionnement des candidats
tirés au sort égalité de temps de parole
à la seconde près et thème de débat
imposé mais très vite c'est la sphère
fillon qui animent les échanges entre
les candidats et françois fillon essaye
de prendre le contre-pied en se
présentant comme le candidat exemplaires
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un président
exemplaire c'est d'abord un président
qui dit la vérité aux français sur la
réalité de la france et la réalité du
monde un président exemplaire c'est un
président qui met en oeuvre les
engagements qu'il a pris devant le
peuple quelles que soient les
difficultés un président exemplaire
c'est un président qui respecte son
premier ministre qui respecte le
gouvernement et qui respecte l'équilibré
des pouvoirs prévus par la constitution
un président exemplaire c'est un
président qui ne se sert pas des moyens
de l'état pour affaiblir ses adversaires
alors dans ce débat il ya un petit
candidat qui se démarque c'est philippe
poutou du nouveau parti anticapitaliste
il n'hésite pas à mettre les pieds dans
le plat des affaires judiciaires de ses
adversaires et il frappe fort fillon
voilà il est en face de moi que des
histoires et plus on fouille plus plus
on sent la corruption puis on sent la
triche et à côté de ça donc
en plus c'est des bonhommes qui nous
explique qu'il faut la rigueur qu'il
faut l'austérité et eux mêmes ils
piquent dans les caisses publiques donc
comme ça oui d'accord merci donc bon
c'est ce que j'ai dit je les dis
ensuite est aussi le pen à côté alors on
va peut-être réagir aussi mais le pain
de pareilles on pique dans les caisses
publiques car là c'est pas c'est pas ici
c'est l'europe alors l'europe pour
quelqu'un qui est anti européen ça se
savait même pas de piquer de l'argent de
l'europe et le pire c'est qu'en plus le
fn qui se dit antisystème le s'emmerde
pas du tout se protègent grâce aux lois
du système grâce à l'immunité
parlementaire et donc nous refuse
d'aller au convocation policière donc
peinard donc là tout ça ça illustre ce
coup là il est pour la folie ça ça
illustre ouais quand nous les convoqués
par la police nous vous voyez par
exemple on a pas d'immunité ouvrière
désolé haut niveau et philippe poutou
roi de la punchline le temps d'une
soirée alors durant ces échanges un
match se dessine entre les deux favoris
emmanuel macron et marine le pen le
candidat dans marche dénonce le
nationalisme que représente son
adversaire du front national ce que vous
proposez
c'est la guerre économique et nous ne
sommes ni la suisse ni la corée du sud
madame le pen la réalité de notre vie
économique c'est que ce seront des
destructions d'emplois ce que vous
proposez c'est le gast le nationalisme
moi je viens d'une région où les
conflits entre justement les pays
d'europe qui est jean lassalle la très
bien rappelé faut savoir d'où on vient
et où cette séparation nous ramènera le
nationalisme c'est la guerre et vous ne
reverrez pas cette année en emmanuel
macron aussi offensive dans un débat de
premier tour par ils refusent d'y
participer
son principal argument un président
sortant ne l'a jamais fait par le passé
[Musique]